Neil. And I have come up with a couple of ways of showing you a transparent
gas in a rather more interesting way. First of all,
like all gases are gone, can be liquified.
It has a melting point and a boiling point.
Both of them slightly higher than the temperature of liquid nitrogen.
[Inaudible].
They're quite unusual because there's barely five degrees
centigrade between the melting point and the boiling point.
Most liquids have quite a long liquid range.
You can hit them quite a bit after they've melted,
before they boil argon has this tiny range.
But Neil,
with his magic experimental fingers has managed to liquefy it
really quite simply in the same way that we make liquid oxygen by
bypassing argon gas through a coil that is cooled with liquid nitrogen,
The algorithm passes through the coil faster than it can freeze.
And you can collect the liquid in the Thermo's flowers. Do you have a vessel?
As you know, we have a special deal vessel. That's not silver,
so you can see what's inside for easily.
And you can see our gone boils as a colorless liquid looks
rather like nitrogen, but if you measured the temperature,
you'd find it was boiling it a slightly high temperature.
I get quite excited saying liquid the Hong Kong,
partly because I've never actually seen it before in the Dewar,
but also because we used to do research using liquid argon
as a solvent.
[Inaudible].
And in fact, I've got the sale we used to use here.
The sales made out of copper and it's cooled with liquid nitrogen that goes
through one of these pipes. And now to the other,
there's a little chamber inside with windows that are transparent to
infrared light. The windows themselves are quite exciting.
Let me show you if I shine my food and through it,
you can see that the windows are red and they're red because they made a
very compound of thallium and broom in an IRD.
And it has the rather name of KRS five.
And because thallium is very poisonous,
you mustn't touch it and you'd spoil the experiments. Anyway, if you touched it,
the reason we were using liquid argon as a solvent is because we were doing
infrared spectroscopy and looking at the spectrum of dissolved
molecules.
Infrared light is absorbed by the vibration of atoms,
but argon has only one atom in the molecule.
So it can't vibrate. So it is completely transparent.
Infrared light, unlike nearly every other solvent motor,
for example, absorbs infrared light very strongly.
So you can have a very dilute solution in liquid argon,
and you can get a wonderful spectrum because it doesn't absorb.
And because it's cold,
you can see the behavior molecules in solution at much lower temperature than
in most other solvents are gone,
is used in the lab as just an inert gas.
When you're handling compounds that react with oxygen.
If you are looking at not very valuable compounds,
you very often will use nitrogen because nitrogen is much cheaper than argon,
but because they add some of argon is much heavier than the molecule of
nitrogen.
It's much more efficient in chasing air out of the remote corners of your
operators. So for really, as sensitive compounds are gone is better.
In the 18th century,
there was some indication when people were analyzing air that there was an extra
1% that was no nitrogen, but they had no means of identifying it.
And it was only in the 1890s that load Riley
and Ramsey first managed to identify all gone,
particularly by putting electric current through the gas and
observing the light that is emitted Neal has got out one of our
Nobel guest stars. This time filled with all guns.
And when you put a current through it,
you can see it gives out a very nice blue color,
quite different from the orange of helium or the right of neon.
And the light consists of a number of lines, different colors,
which is essentially what was observed at the end of the 19th century.
When argon was identified,
the name argon apparently comes from the Greek word,
meaning idle because it doesn't react with other things,
but even that's not correct now because there are a
whole series of experiments that have been done looking at the reaction to
valgum at low temperature.
And if you condense all gone and hydrogen fluoride HF
at 20 degrees,
absolute and shine light on them to dissociate the HF,
you can make a molecule, which is hydrogen argon, fluorine.
It's only stable at very low temperature,
but there was huge excitement when it was discovered because it was the first
compound of outcome. Well,
it wasn't quite the first compound because early on in
my career, my fellow student,
Robin Perutz was studying the reactions of a chromium compound
in solid argon at 20 degrees.
Absolute the molecules were isolated a bit like the cherries in a
cake. And when you shine light on the chromium compounds,
they dissociated and the chromium atom could react or
interact with are gone. Now, it wasn't a very strong bond,
but it was enough to change the color of the compound.
And it made a beautiful purple color,
which I photographed and have used as a slide ever since the
final.
And I have to admit perhaps slightly boring application of argon
is in double glazing to keep our houses warm because argon
has a heavy atom.
The atoms don't move very fast in the gas phase and therefore they're
bad conducting heat. So if you have double glazing,
that's two sheets of glass in your window.
If you put out in between the glass,
it is much more effective and insulating the
inside of the house, keeping cold out.
Then if you use air,
because air has a much higher conductivity of heat.
So if you look out to the window,
you may find that you're looking through argon gas.
[Inaudible].